be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while I play video
games and talk to you about random life
stuff
what's going on guys this is Rob and
because I already have videos on the
history and life of apocalypse as well
as as Four Horsemen I figured why not
make a video covering his powers and
what I'm hoping is that at the end of
this you'll have a strong understanding
of what apocalypse is capable of as well
as why he's considered one of the most
formidable threats of the x-men and
Marvel Comics so first and foremost
apocalypse is extremely intelligent with
his intellect being surpassed by only a
handful of people including Reed
Richards
Black Panther and Doctor Doom and the
reason why is that as one of the oldest
mutants on earth he has around 5,000
years worth of life experience in
addition to knowledge on virtually all
forms of science due to having come into
contact with the celestial ship which
contains technology thousands of years
beyond that currently found on earth in
addition to this apocalypse is an
extremely capable demagogue meaning he's
able to rally the beliefs or desires of
people towards a single cause as an
example while there is a video
explaining the history of his Four
Horsemen very rarely does apocalypse
actually force individuals to become his
horseman instead he usually preys on
those who were in a weakened mindset as
was seen with Bruce Banner an archangel
or feeds into their pride as was seen
with Wolverine allowing apocalypse to
essentially trick them into joining his
cause furthermore apocalypse pops up and
some of these weird locations before
example during the onslaught saga which
was a story focusing on the emotions of
Charles Xavier and Magneto merging into
a psychic bean apocalypse spent a brunt
of the event watching things unfold
alongside who ought to the watcher and
was funny about this is that because he
maintains a social Darwinists ideology
and that the weak should perish to make
way for the strong his argument was that
he was not going to intervene because
the battle with onslaught would reveal
the week of evening kind and those who
were too weak to defeat onslaught didn't
deserve to exist however when a watch of
the watcher came along and said that if
onslaught wins he's going to destroy
everything which included apocalypse
apocalypse actually changed his tune and
assisted in helping to defeat onslaught
now in terms of what most people
clicking on this video we're looking to
see the powers of apocalypse exist in
two forms three celestial technology and
post celestial technology
coming out of the story rise of
apocalypse which gave us a first look at
his inherent Newton powers apocalypse
his abilities were relatively
straightforward when he first appeared
because he held an affection for a woman
named Nephi but was rebuked too due to
his physical appearance in terms of his
grey skin and blue lines his powers
manifested in the same fashion as all
mutants what I mean here is that within
Marvel Comics
mutant powers emerge as a result of
stress hormonal development during
puberty or combination of both with
regards to apocalypse because the
rejection of Nephi fed back into the
abandonment issues he faced when his
original tribe left him to die under the
idea that his physical form signified a
bad omen his emotions reached a boiling
point
triggering the activation of his
enhanced speed strength stamina and
immortality while he would use these
powers to essentially lay waste to Egypt
and wipe away the old order allowing for
the establishment of a pharaoh
monarchies as we know them today what
his revolution ended he used his
abilities to travel the world planting
the seeds of future plans by pitting
various cultures against one another to
eliminate the weak but also looking to
expand on his own power the covered in
cable and Deadpool vol 1 issues 26 and
27 titled with eyes closed parts one and
two in the early days of his rule
apocalypse had stumbled across a ship
containing celestial technology to
sidetrack here if you recall my
discussion on the Celestials we talked
about how they existed as a kind of
exploratory race of cosmic aliens who
travel the universe influencing
different planets in different ways
where little is known about their
escapades outside of Earth what we do
know is that their arrival came with the
experimentation on early man leading to
the formation of deviants Eternals and
eventually mutants covered in Neil
Gaiman's run of the Eternals unlike
deviants Annie Turtles who saw immediate
results from the Celestials experiments
mutants came as a result of the
Celestials planting the X gene which is
programmed to emerge after 15,000 years
leading to the appearance of Selene as
the first mutant twelve thousand years
before apocalypse is birth that said
during the early years of his life
apocalypse had stumbled across the ship
left on earth by the Celestials but was
unable to access it due to the
technology being beyond his ability to
understand
however after encountering cable
operating as the traveler because cable
had looked to kill apocalypse before he
could rise to power after the two had
engaged in battle cables techno-organic
blood merged with apocalypse allowing
him to access the celestial ship covered
in x-men vol 2 issues 182 through 186 as
part of the decimation storyline
following the house of M which saw the
Scarlet Witch stripping ninety-eight
percent of the mutant population of
their powers where the main event saw
apocalypse intending to use his blood as
a means to jumpstart Mutant evolution
and restore their powers a backstory was
provided stating that after accessing
the ship Apocalypse spoke directly with
one of the Celestials and was given a
choice walk away without proceeding
further and live his life naturally or
borrow the ship's technology with the
requirement that he has to suffer
payments later deciding to use the ship
to his own ends apocalypses existing
mutant powers were enhanced several
times over meaning he was virtually
immune to harm from all but the
strongest beings in existence but also
possessed virtually every superhuman
power including telekinesis telepathy
energy manipulation invisibility
shape-shifting a healing factor
super-strength on par with Thor and the
Hulk and the ability to control the
molecular structure of his body
transforming his physical form into
whatever he desired or growing to
massive sizes now other had been several
instances in which apocalypse is faced
off against powerful beings like Thor
the most impressive came an x-factor
volume 1 issue number 68 centering on
the revelation that apocalypse his vast
abilities were too extreme for his body
this story revealed that in order to
survive he would have to transfer his
essence from one host to the next for
the rest of eternity looking to achieve
this goal with Cyclops and madelyn prior
producing a son named Nathan his
omega-level telepathic and telekinetic
abilities made him the perfect host for
apocalypses essence taking place in the
story bitter sacrifices after
discovering that apocalypse had
kidnapped Nathan and taken him to the
blue area of the moon which was a
section containing oxygen Cyclops
assembled the full roster of the x-men
x-factor x-force and the Inhumans in
order to take his son back launching an
attack against the Citadel while
apocalypses henchmen were defeated
almost immediately he was able to take
on the entire roster of heroes
meta point now the significance of this
in this battle some of the people who
apocalypse was fighting included the
adult cable Jean Grey Black Bolt whose
voice could shatter planets Iceman who's
one of the most powerful mutants in the
world Professor Xavier and Colossus in
addition to this while the story would
see apocalypse forced to retreat someone
who take note of is that he wasn't
technically defeated instead the massive
use of energy left him completely
exhausted and unable to maintain the
fight that said in terms of his
weaknesses this is really the only one
unlike individuals like Thanos whose
incredible power is a result of his own
genetic mutation or cybernetic
enhancements the powers of apocalypse
work against him as opposed to in
support of them as a result every so
often he literally has to vacate his
position in the mobile landscape travel
back to Egypt and recharges energies for
a thousand years or so during his time
while he is still extremely dangerous
apocalypse is actually in his weakest
form relatively speaking and is
incapable of defending himself
adequately against a foe of equal or
slightly lesser strength as an example
during the Messiah Complex story which
focus on the birth of Hope Summers as a
first feat in following the house of M
but her existence triggered a literal
mad dash from individuals who sought to
use her ability to copy powers to take
over the world while cables served as
her protector his clone strife remained
alive and well as an omega-level
telepath and telekinetic with no equal
aside from Jean Grey and Emma Frost
accepting the offer of Bishop to help
capture hope due to the fact that Bishop
hails from a future where hope would
become a villain and kill 1 million
humans and mutants in a six-second war
during the messiah wars story
k.will enlisted the aid of apocalypse
deadpool and x-force leading to a
massive fight between strife and Bishop
and the rest of the group now because
strife and apocalypse share a mutual
hatred which was covered in my video on
the origins of cable the powers of
strife were more than apocalypse
bargained for leading to his near death
until he was saved by the actions of
archangel who used his blood to
rejuvenate apocalypse now while a story
would see strife defeated and cable
escaping with hope this highlights the
fact that despite his vaunted powers
even at full strength and barring
characters like franklin richards
apocalypse can still be defeated by
those with sufficient power and energy
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and let me know what you
guys think about apocalypse in the x-men
movie I'm actually really curious to see
how things unfold and I will catch you
guys later peace